♪
>> Tucker: IT'S THURSDAY,
TIME FINAL EXAM.
WHICH FOX EMPLOYEES AND
CONTRIBUTOR HAVE BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO THEIR JOBS
COVERING THE NEWS.
THIS WEEK'S CORRESPONDENT
GRIFF JENKINS AND FOX NEWS
AT NIGHT HOST SHANNON BREAM.
SHANNON HAS BEEN A BUZZ SAW
SIX OPPONENTS SHE HAS FACED.
HERE ARE HER OPPONENTS FROM
WEEKS' PAST.
WOW THAT IS JUST A MURDEROUS
ROW.
PERHAPS GRIFF IS UP TO THE
GIVE YOU A FIGHTING CHANCE,
MAYBE IT'S THE SEAT THAT'S
BEEN DOING IT.
>> I HAVE BEEN PUT IN THE
THUNDER DOME.
>> I KNOW, ALL OF MY GOOD
MOJO IS ON THAT CHAIR AND
THAT BUZZER.
>> Tucker: OUR PRODUCER
ALEX McCASS SKILL WHO
WROTE THESE QUESTIONS SAID
THESE QUESTIONS ARE TOUGH.
WAIT UNTIL I FINISH ASKING
THE QUESTION TO DO THAT.
IF YOU GET IT WRONG YOU LOSE
A POINT.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
WINNER WILL BE AWARD ADD
PRIZE I WILL KEEP SECRET FOR
THE MOMENT.
OKAY, FIRST UP.
ONE OF DONALD TRUMP'S
CELEBRITY ARCH ENEMIES
POSSIBLY FACING JAIL TIME
OF DOLLARS TO REPUBLICAN
SENATORS TO REJECT THE TAX
BILL.
[BUZZER]
>> YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
I'M FINISHED.
WHICH CELEBRITY WAS IT?
SHANNON BREAM?
ALL RIGHT.
TRICKED BY THE RULES.
WE WILL SEE IF SHE IS RIGHT
TO THE TAPE.
IS IT ROSIE O'DONNELL?
>> ROSIE O'DONNELL GOING OFF
THE RAILS TRYING TO STOP THE
TAX BILL ON A TWITTER TIRADE
TWEETING IN PART, QUOTE:
HOW ABOUT THIS?
I PROMISE TO GIVE $2 MILLION
TO SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS AND
MANY ON TWITTER KICK TO
POINT OUT THOSE BRIBES WOULD
BE ILLEGAL.
SHE ALSO TOLD HER FOLLOWERS
TO CALL 911.
>> Tucker: IT'S LIKE THE
HAGUE.
WE HAVE TO FOLLOW THE RULES
HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WELL DONE.
>> THE OTHER SIX GO UP.
>> YEAH THEY DO.
>> Tucker: MARIST COLLEGE IS
OUT WITH THE POLL MOST
ANNOYING WORDS AND PHRASES
OF 2017.
ALMOST THE MOST ANNOYING IN
HUMAN HISTORY.
SECOND PLACE WITH THE PHRASE
FAKE NEWS WHICH ANNOYING
>> WHATEVER.
>> Tucker: NO, WHICH
>> Tucker: TO THE TAPE IS,
WHATEVER CORRECT?
>> THE MOST ANNOYING WORDS.
FAKE NEWS, THAT'S SECOND.
IT GOT 23% OF THE VOTE.
LOOK AT THAT NUMBER ONE,
WHATEVER.
>> LOOK AT YOU.
HIGH FIVE.
>> WHATEVER.
>> IT'S THE MOST ANNOYING
>> YEAH, WHATEVER.
>> SHE IS GOOD.
DON'T BE FOOLED BY THE NICEY
NICEY.
>> IT'S ON.
>> Tucker: IT'S 1 TO 1.
APPLE, THE COMPANY IS IN
TROUBLE WITH ITS CUSTOMERS
AFTER ADMITTING IT
DELIBERATELY DOES WHAT TO
ITS OLDER iPHONES?
LONG-TIME CONSPIRACY THEORY
OLDER iPHONES AFTER SOME
OF THE NEWER MODELS ARE
RELEASED IT DOES THIS NOT TO
PUSH PEOPLE TO BUY THE NEWER
MODELS THAT ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE BUT INSTEAD TO
KEEP THE OLDER PHONES FROM
CRASHING.
>> I HAVE AN OLD iPHONE I
FEEL LIKE IT'S SLOWING ME
DOWN.
I SPEAK FROM EXPERIENCE.
>> Tucker: YOUR ANSWER WAS
CORRECT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THEIR
EXPLANATION.
IT'S REALLY FOR YOUR BENEFIT
THAT WE'RE MAKING THE PHONE
SO BAD YOU NEED TO BUY A NEW
ONE.
>> PEOPLE MOCK ME HOW SLOW
THIS PHONE IS.
>> Tucker: APPLE IS HERE TO
HELP YOU, SHANNON.
>> RIGHT, YES.
>> Tucker: THIS WEEK A
FORMER NAVY PILOT REVEALED
ON THIS SHOW, ACTUALLY, THAT
AN OBJECT IN THE SKY, HE
HE DESCRIBED THIS
UNIDENTIFIED FLYING OBJECT
AS BEING IN THE SHAPE OF
CANDY.
WHICH CANDY WAS IT SHAPED
LIKE?
WAS IT A A TIC-TACS?
B A CANDY CORN?
C A SKILL, AND I WILL THROW
IN D BUTTER FINGER.
>> THIS IS THROWING IT OUT
THERE BECAUSE I HAVE NO
IDEA.
BUT I LIKE TIC-TACSS.
>> Tucker: YOU LIKE
TIC-TACSS.
GRIFF LIKES TIC-TACSS HE
CAME ACROSS AN AIRCRAFT THAT
HE SAYS QUOTE WAS NOT
TIC-TACS.
IT HAD NO SWINGS.
>> Shannon: LOOK AT YOU.
YOU GOT TO GO ALL IN AGAINST
A VERY, VERY ASTUTE.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TO THE
PRECIPICE OF VICTORY OVER
SHANNON BREAM.
IN FACT THEY ARE LITTERED ON
THE VALLEY FLOOR THEIR
QUESTION.
ARE YOU READY?
ARE YOU FEELING GOOD.
>> NO, I'M NOT.
>> Tucker: GOOD HANDS ON THE
BUZZER.
ARE YOU READY?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: DISNEY UNVEILED
NEW ROBOT VERSION OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S IN THE HALL OF THE
ROBOT LOOKS NOTHING LIKE THE
PRESIDENT BUT LIKE WHICH
ACTOR INSTEAD?
SHANNON BREAM.
>> JON
>> JOHN VOIGHT.
>> SOME ON THE INTERNET SAY
IT LOOKS LIKE A BLOATED JOHN
VOIGHT.
JOHN VOIGHT IS NEVER GOING
TO SPEAK TO ME AGAIN.
>> Tucker: LOOK AT THAT
SHANNON BREAM, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
OKAY, SO YOU WIN, THIS WEEK
WE RUN OUT OF PRIZES.